This is Jocko podcast number
48 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Yeah.
We found general Custer on the bluffs
and near him lay the bodies of 11 of his
officers as a tribute to his bravery.
The Indians had not mutilated general
Custer and he lay as if asleep,
but all the other men had been most
brutally mangled and had been stripped of
their clothing.
Yeah.
Many of their skulls had been crushed in
eyes, had been torn from their sockets,
hands, feet, arms, legs,
and noses had been wrenched off.
Many had their flesh cut in strips the
entire length of their bodies and there
were others whose limbs were closely
perforated with bullet holes showing that
the torture had been inflicted while
the wretched victims were yet alive.
There were 29 enlisted men missing from
the field of blood and they undoubtedly
had been taken prisoners and perished
at the steak while the Indians were
celebrating their scalp dance on the
night of the 25th in sight of my camp,
mine almost at Custer's feet was young.
Read a nephew of the generals who had
been visiting him at Fort Lincoln and who
had pleaded to go on the campaign where
this handsome lad of 19 met such an
untimely fate
within a few feet of the general lay,
his two brothers,
Boston and Tom.
There wasn't a whole army, no more
popular man than gallon. Tom Custer.
He was young,
handsome,
a prince of good fellows and full of
that bravery that even characterized the
coasters.
He had served with distinction during
the war and it fought frequently before,
been engaged in Indian fights.
As we approached him,
we were horrified to see that his body
had been opened in his heart torn out.
Thus,
I know that the vengeance of rain in
the face had been at work several years
before.
Rain in the face had murdered two white
men on of our forte and afterwards
boasted of it in the reservation.
He was arrested and brought
to trial by Tom Koster,
but before the time appointed
for his case at arrived,
the wily Indian had escaped sending back
word to captain Tom that he would be
revenged by cutting out his captors heart.
Okay.
Rain in the face kept his
word by literally tearing
out the heart of young Tom
Koster near these three brothers
and they're boyish nephew lay there
brother-in-law, lieutenant Calhoun,
who had fallen on the skirmish line.
Costumers command was
completely annihilated,
not one of his men escaping.
Good Evening Echo. Good
evening, not right. There is
an excerpt from a book called,
I fought with Custer,
which is the story of Charles Wind off
who was a young private that fought with
one of the other companies in the
same Seventh Cavalry Regiment.
That general George Custer led
general George Custer,
who was killed at the battle of little
big horn where he fought the native
Americans,
including our friend wouldn't leg or
we heard from on podcasts 45 but the
opening section that I just read wasn't
actually written by pro private wind off
it is a section of an account that is
written by a guy named major reno who was
one of the leaders of one of the other
companies have men at the battle that
they include in this book.
This book called by fought with customer
and this was obviously a brutal battle.
And my goal as always,
I shouldn't say is always put my goal.
Yeah.
Well where I like to focus is not so much
on what details happen in the battle,
but what details happened with
the human nature in the battle,
the people, the leadership, the decisions.
And we got some good understanding about
the native American perspective from
wooden leg.
But now let's hear a little bit of
what it was like for the troopers.
And I know I use that term
on a fairly regular basis,
but that is a very specific term.
Okay.
In a cavalry unit,
this,
and at this time a cavalry unit was
literally units that they ride horses,
you know, that's what
it is. Mounted Cavalry,
a soldier in a calvary unit is
specifically called a trooper.
And the word nowadays,
it,
it actually is used to cover a
lot of different people. You know,
armored units use it,
airborne units. You know,
when you think of an airborne unit
parachuters, you think of a paratrooper,
trooper being the key word there.
Obviously there's police state troopers.
And then obviously there's people
that listen to this podcast,
but that is what we have here.
The cavalry unit,
and this in particular was the Seventh
Cavalry Regiment and the trooper,
like I said,
is this guy private Charles wind off
who's actually born in Germany and
emigrated to the United States.
He became a cobbler like his
dad knew what a cobbler is.
People fix shoes.
People who fix shoes and you know what,
he fixed shoes for awhile, but he didn't
like fixing shoes, so what do you do?
Join the army and he ended up
fighting in some of the Indian wars.
He actually received the medal of honor
for his actions at little big horn and
we'll get into those,
but let's hear what private
wind off has to say.
I'm going to the book,
June 25th,
1946 was the last time I saw him alive.
Two days later I looked down on him
lying in the white in the Montana son.
That would have been June 27th,
1876 and the following day I helped him.
I helped bury him and his brother,
Captain Tom Koster.
They were putting in graves
alongside one another.
It was hard digging there on that high
ridge that bordered little big horn.
It's a long time to remember
details and little things,
but when you've been thinking
back on them all those years,
they don't fade away as easily as
you might think. They're like burrs.
They stick in your mind.
People call it the Koster massacre.
It wasn't any massacre.
It was a straight hard fight and the five
troops who were with Costa simply got
cut to ribbons and every
last white man destroyed.
I say every last white man because there
were one or two crow scouts who claim
they saw the start of the fight and then
skedaddled a crow Indian named curly
said he escaped from the battlefield
by putting a blanket over his head and
pretending he was a wounded sue.
Okay.
I don't know whether there's any truth in
that or not. I never quite believed it.
There's been all kinds of
stories about that battle.
Even the men who were with Ben Teen and
Reno and live to tell the tale didn't
come anywhere near telling the same
stories about what they did and what they
saw.
Some of them wanted to make heroes out
of themselves or of their officers.
I only had one pair of eyes,
so of course all I can
tell is what I saw myself.
If it is something that I only heard,
I'll be sure to mark it down as that.
Interestingly,
this is something that we used to see
all the time in that you go out on an
operation and when things happen to guys,
almost nobody will see the same thing.
Everybody sees some things a little bit
different and it can be difficult to
figure out what's actually accurate.
So that's,
and he's, he's going back
when he's writing this book,
I think it's been 70 years.
So when he's being interviewed
and he's writing this book,
it's been 70 years and he's saying
he still remembers the details,
but 70 years is a long time,
long time.
And the characters that
he just brought up,
Ben teen is a guy that he worked for
and Reno was one of the other majors.
And another word that they use here
is truth. Now this is a word that's,
we think of it as an individual.
Hey,
there's a trooper over there or
that there's a troop. It actually,
it actually is another term that means
basically like a company of guys.
Now you can see it small and
this is more like a platoon.
What they're talking about
would be considered a platoon,
I would say from reading.
Um,
he had five troops with him. Koster
did that got killed, you know, call.
How about 200 guys?
And so we're not talking about a
massive group of people in each troop,
but that's what they're talking about.
20 guys per trooper actually.
What'd that be?
40 guys per troop for five.
And so that's what they're talking
when they refer to the troops.
And even they use the word interchangeably
and sometimes they'll refer to as
companies and sometimes they say troops.
Yeah.
So um,
guilt going back to the book here when
he's an initially in the army and what
they're doing and he talks about
what they were doing at this time.
It was pretty dull soldiering
down there in the south,
the regiment was broken up into companies
or small battalions and our job was to
smash the Klu Klux Klan and run
down elicit whiskey distillers.
It wasn't much fun for
energetic spirited young men.
And now he's going to talk a little bit
about the seventh cavalry. As I say,
the seventh cavalry was only seven
years old in 1873 but it had a fine
reputation. Everybody in the
country knew general Custer
and Andy and he was always bragging about
what a fine fighting regimen he had.
He was supposed to be the best Indian
fighter in the American army in the civil
war.
They'd called them the boy
general and he'd been a dashing,
popular figure.
The regimen had spent its first four
years of its life on the Kansas Plains and
an Indian Indian territory.
The old timers in the outfit could sure
tell some blood curling Indian stories.
They used to say that it
was worse straight death to
get captured by the Indians
because you would be slowly tortured
until you gave up the ghost.
They told all of us young soldiers,
if we were ever wounded in an Indian fight
and left behind and endanger of being
captured,
that we must save our last
cartridge to blow out our brains.
So that's an interesting point.
When we remember,
wouldn't leg said that all the guys in
costers group ended up killing themselves
and maybe that's that.
That very well might have happened
or at least some of them.
Yeah.
Back to the book.
By the spring of 1873 the plains
Indians had been largely debased,
beaten,
and driven to the great reservations
that have been allotted to the various
tribes. It had not been a
deliberate government policy,
but it had been cruelly,
but had been a cruelly effective one.
Treaty after treaty had been broken by
the relentless pressure of white men and
their civilization constantly pushing
against the ineffective resistance of the
red men. Now, when again,
the Indians had struck back and
as a rule, they're angry, angry,
flare ups were put down by the army,
and then new and drastic treaties would
be made and more land taken from them in
punishment.
The ink would hardly be dry on these new
government commitments before the white
pressure would be resumed. Intrusions
made. And once again, the bewildered,
enraged Indians would strike back only
to be subdued by the army and harsh
penalties imposed on them.
It was a deadly and vicious cycle.
The Indian found himself
whirling endlessly in.
So that's reminds me of a lot
of conflicts where you have,
you have these things
happen. You know the, the,
the white man is putting
pressure on the Indians.
The Indians don't know what's going on,
so they lash out a little bit.
What are the white man do
then go in there, smash them,
take more land from them,
compress the more.
Eventually there's another lash out
and you just get this vicious cycle,
vicious cycle.
In 1864,
uh,
certain kernel Shillington with a regimen
of volunteer Colorado Cav cavalry had
suddenly moved against a large encampment
of Cheyanne's and indiscriminately
killed some 300 Indians.
The massacre unquestionably had turned
many Luke warm Indians into out and out
hostiles. This bitterness of
the Cheyanne's was inflamed.
Two or three years later
when costs are led,
his newly formed seventh cavalry against
the black kettle and his band in a
sudden attack against their sleeping
village on Washita in Texas,
the Cheyanne's who are recognized as the
most brilliant Indian fighters of the
planes never forgave either Custer or
his seventh cavalry for this whirling
attack on their sleeping
village in the dead of winter.
Oh, another big. Yeah. So, uh, you know,
atrocities on both sides,
clearly,
I'll talk a little bit
about those as well.
But one of the biggest atrocities beyond
the killing of the Indians themselves,
that native Americans themselves and those
types of atrocities was what they did
with the buffalos because the white
man was coming and killing all the
buffaloes.
And I'll go to the book here.
Once the buffalo around whose existence
the whole economy of the Indian was
based,
was killed off the nomads,
had nothing to do but submit to government
control and become agency Indians,
degraded whiskey crazed and beaten only
the various tribes of the Su and the
fighting Cheyenne is refused to be
broken on the wheel of civilization.
A few determine leaders such
as sitting bull, crazy horse,
gall American horse to moon,
white bull spotted eagle and chief honk.
Stubbornly held out against the threats
and blandishments of the whites.
But by the spring of 1873 they were
beginning to be branded as hostiles.
So that's something that
I didn't focus on enough.
When I talked about how the Sioux
and the Cheyenne kind of faded well,
one of the main reasons that
they faded was, you know, again,
they gave up their guns at
a certain point, but we,
the white man had decimated the buffaloes.
And so that was their main way of
survival. If you remember from wooden leg,
that's where they lived.
They lived in shelters that were made
from buffalo skins and obviously they ate
buffalo all the time. They
hunted buffalo, they ate them.
They made their weapons out of Buffalo.
Everything that they did was with Buffalo.
Yeah,
so when the white man came in and killed
all the buffalo, that put them in a,
in a real precarious situation.
Now we go back to the book talking to a
little bit about what it was like being
the cavalry at this time.
Each man would look after his own horse
and we'd usually give him a little
exercise and a good rub down.
A trooper thought a lot
of his mouth at a cavalry,
men would have to be a pretty mean.
It would have to be pretty mean.
Who didn't take good care of his horse.
If we got a good chance, we'd steal them.
A little extra oats or
hay for individual mounts.
My horse at this time was named pig.
That wasn't his real name,
but I called him that because nothing
could keep him from rolling in a mud hole
when he was being watered.
After we'd come in from a long ride.
He was fast and he could show his heels
to most of the horses and the regimen.
I fought a lot of them,
but the army condemned him after we'd
been beaten in the Dakota country.
A year or two after we'd been in
the Dakota country, a year or two,
I'll tell you later about the horse.
I rode in the battle of little big horn,
but one more thing about pig.
Two or three years after the army
sold him, I saw him in a contractor,
six horse team and the black hills.
He looked so porn abused.
I'd have bought them from
that contractor on the spot,
but I didn't have the money. I went
up to him and tested him. He knew me.
All right. He nickered and looked at me
as much to say, come on please Charlie,
get me out of here.
I had written old pig thousands
of miles and more than once,
he had saved my life at pretty
near cried when I saw him.
That time in the black hills.
Big Connection and you know,
we see that nowadays with the guys that
work with dogs and the the military
working dogs, which are awesome animals
and those guys get major connect,
majorly connected to those dogs.
So she's like horse where it's just,
there's a lot of times where
it's just you and him in the,
in the first year writing situation,
you know, it's just you and him.
It's like Dang,
you go through so much together,
up stones and then for sure you could,
I can't even imagine the
emotion of that situation. Yeah.
Back to the book, it was at the Yankton
that I first saw general Custer.
He was not far from six feet tall.
He must have weighed around 180 pounds.
He was energetic and it was
mighty hard to wear him out.
I've heard people say that
when he was at West Point,
he was the second strongest man there.
As I remember him at the time,
he was wearing long hair or something
like buffalo bill used to where you had a
big wide Brynn,
western hat and long military mustache,
his hair and mustache where
yellow Tawney colored.
I suppose would be the
right way to describe them.
He had on high Willington boots,
they were the kind that came up to the
knees with the front three or four inches
higher than the back. They were
popular among officers at the time.
General customer wasn't the
kind to mix freely with the men.
In those years there was quite a gulf
between the officers and the enlisted men.
Some of the officers were friendly
and easy going with their troopers,
but there was always a Gulf Kuster
struck me as being aloof and removed.
No did
it got to be gossip among the troopers
that some of the officers didn't set so
very well with the general,
my captain,
Colonel Ben Teen. So there's something
that nurses like, I got to point this out.
Some of these including general Custer,
these guys had been promoted
during the civil war.
It's so general become a
general during the civil war,
but after the war they got demoted.
They got put back down in rank
cause they shrank the armies,
they shrank the army.
And so for instance,
general Custer at this time was he
had been a general in the civil war.
Now all of a sudden he's a colonel,
so he'd got put down in rank and it's the
same with, he's talking about his boss.
Um, uh, uh, wind offs.
Boss Windows boss was a
guy named captain Ben Teen,
but they call him colonel bending cause
he was a colonel during civil war.
[inaudible]
my captain Colonel Benton was one of
those folks who didn't belong to the
generals inner circle,
I suppose you could say about
half the officers in the regiment,
we're close to Costa
and the rest were not.
I repeat that Ben teen was not distinct,
was distinctly not an intimate of Custer.
I heard all sorts of
reasons why that was true.
There was one report that Ben teen,
it turned bitter because Costa had
pulled out after the battle of the washy,
didn't December,
1868 in Kansas and it left a major
Elliot and 17 men to their fate.
A day or two later they were all found,
killed,
scalped and mutilated.
There was a story that Custer and Ben
Teen had some hard words over that,
but of course,
I don't know how true that old story is.
So there you go. Ben Teen thought
custard, let some guys hanging out to dry,
had confronted him about it and
cost or didn't like that at all,
and now they got some stuff
that they're at odds about.
And speaking of that event where
these 17 men were killed in this book,
they have an exer that's a letter from
an army officer that got published in a
newspaper about that event,
and I'm going to read it.
The bodies were found in a small circle,
stripped as naked as wind born and frozen,
stiff.
Their heads had been battered in and some
of them had been entirely chopped off.
Some of them had the Adam's
apple cut out of their throats.
Some had their hands and feet caught
off and nearly all had been horribly
mangled in a way.
Delicacy forbids me to mention.
Yeah,
they lay scarcely two miles
from the scene of the fight.
Okay.
Who can describe the
feeling of that brave band?
As with anxious hearts beating,
they strained their yearning eyes in
the direction of whence the help should
come.
What must've been the despair that when
all hopes of soccer died out nerve,
they're stout arms to do and
die round and round rush.
The red feens smaller and
smaller shrinks the circle.
But the aim of that devoted gallon not
of heroes is steadier than ever and the
death. How of the murderous
red skin is more frequent,
but on a calm and masses
grim with glittering lance
and one long loud exalting
whoop as if the gates of hell had opened
and loose the whole infernal host.
Okay,
well directed volley from their trustee
carbines make some of the miscreants
real and fall, but their death rattles
are drowned in the greater den.
Okay?
Soon every voice in that
little band is steel is death,
but the hellish work of the savages is
scarce begun and their engine newies are
taxed to invent barbarities to practice
on the bodies of the fallen brave.
Yeah.
Some psychological warfare going on there.
You clearly,
we know that the troopers at this time do.
You don't want to get
captured by the Indians.
And the reason that they think that
is events like this mutilated bodies,
everyone had killed.
No quarter given.
Now going to what some of
the other officers were like,
I'm gonna talk about Captain Ben Teen.
Here's what captain Benton
was like back to the book.
Most of the time we were in the field.
Captain venting commanded a squadron.
Usually you'd have one or two
companies besides his own h company.
He was a wonderful officer.
He let the first sergeant pretty
much run the company. Hmm.
Little decentralized command going on.
He wasn't always interfering
and running the details,
so he wasn't getting in the weeds.
He wasn't a micromanager.
I served under Ben Team for 12 full years,
lacking only throws three days.
One of the best descriptions of Captain
Benton is that penned by the late major
general Hugh l Scott on page
454 of his interesting book,
some memoirs of a soldier.
I found my model early
in captain Ben Teen,
the idol of the seventh cavalry on the
Upper Missouri in 1877 who governed
mainly by suggestion.
In all the years I knew him,
I never once heard him raise his
voice to enforce his purpose.
Think about that.
Never once heard him raise his
voice to enforce his purpose.
He would sit by the open fire at night,
his bright,
pleasant face framed by a snow white
hair beaming with kindness and humor,
and often watched often I watched his
every movement to find out the secret of
his quiet, steady government
that I might go and govern.
Likewise,
for example,
if he to stay a few days in one camp,
he would say to his adjutant,
brewer,
don't you think we had better take up
our regular guard Mount Wallen camp?
And brewer always thought it
better and so did everyone else.
If he found this kindly manner,
manner was misunderstood,
then his iron hand would close quickly
down. But that was seldom necessary.
And then only with newcomers and
never twice with the same person.
So this is just complete example of
indirect leadership. Hey, don't you hey,
echo, do anything to be good. If
we're going to stay in this camp,
we should put our, our camp guards
out. Hm. What do you think? Of course.
There you go. So you make it
happen. I didn't give you an order.
I actually let you get, get some ownership
of it. It's actually now your decision.
Not even my decision anymore.
You know,
that's a really good example
of some solid leadership.
Okay.
Here's what it was like
to be in the cavalry.
It was wonderful to be young and to be
riding into Indian country as part of the
finest regimen of cavalry in the world.
We,
we're mighty proud of the seventh.
It just didn't seem like
anything could ever happen to it.
Now I'm going to go through there.
They're riding out there,
they're working the plains,
and I'm going to go through a little
battle on the planes were customers and
charge general George Custer's in charge.
The general started,
so did the Indians.
They had a good start in general cost of
resolve not to pursue them too far away
from his men after a sharp short race.
He stopped on the plane keeping
well away from the suspicious woods.
When he stopped,
the Indian stopped.
It was evident that they would not
be so audacious without a conscious,
without a consciousness of
strength somewhere for ways
that are dark and tricks
that are vain.
The even sue is almost as
peculiar as the heathen.
Cheney and I actually had to go in
and do a little research on that one.
There's a poem that it's about Chinese
migrant workers and interested.
You can go and read about this poem.
It's called the heathen shiny.
And if you read the poem,
you realize that
he's trying to describe that
they're playing cards with the,
a couple of the people working on the
train or plane cars or the Chinese guy,
and as they're playing cards,
they're,
they're kind of treating the
Chinese guy like he's ignorant,
but he's actually winning. And when they
accused him of cheating, there's a fight.
And he was actually the white guy that
was cheating one of the other white guys
that was cheating.
So the guy that wrote the poem had the
poem with the intention of showing, Hey,
these people are smart
and they're trustworthy,
but because of the name it got
red and misinterpreted a lot.
The title of the poem.
Yep. Yeah. Then shiny,
not a very positive positive neighbor.
At least that's kind of what I did some
very quick research on that just to
figure it out what is all about and that's
sort of what I gathered after a quick
uh,
okay.
Quick research meaning I googled it and
read a few articles to figure out what
was going on in um,
in Hawaiian Pidgin.
When we see Japanese we say Japanese.
Portuguese is put Aggie Chinese,
Chinese man,
right. Be So maybe based on relationship
connection there. All right.
Back to the book.
This time the trick was indeed vein.
They were fighting with no novice.
As soon as general Custer
saw the Indian dodge,
which was to use these men as a
decoy to draw them into the woods,
he immediately sent his orderly back
to Captain Moylan to order a platoon to
dismount before the order could get back.
250 mounted Indians drawn
up in a line of battle,
came out of the woods
and find military style.
The seventh cavalry could hardly have
done it better with painted faces,
heads decorated with ribbons.
They sallied out with loud war.
Whoops. General Custer
putting more confidence in
the feet of his thoroughbred.
Then the voice of his rifle against
250 Indians turned back to his command
calling out to his brother to
throw out a dismounted line.
Lieutenant Custer had anticipated the
order and was already dismounting as men.
That's awesome. So these guys were worked
together. He goes to give the order.
His brother's already on it. They ran
forward and took places in the grass.
The Indians open to heavy fire,
which was quickly answered by our
men with their sharp carbines,
Ena dismounted cavalry fight.
Every fourth man is usually
detailed to hold the horses.
But being short of fighting men and the
reserves being several miles back with
the train general Custer ordered every
six men only to hold the horses and the
rest to join the skirmish line.
The Indians having three times as larger
force and seeing the cavalry dismounted
followed their example and dismounted
from their advantage of numbers.
They were able to extend the skirmish
line clear around from river to river so
as to enclose the cavalry in a semi circle
with the woods and the river at their
back.
They're getting flanked.
Finding though that the
horses were exposed to fire.
General Custer ordered them to
be led further into the timber.
Okay.
Now some other things take place and
I'm kind of fast forward a little bit
through the story.
The Indians having lost two men were more
cautious in their advance and finding
that they could not with their heavy
rifles, drive the cavalry into the woods,
had recourse to another favorite weapon.
They fired the grass in
four or five places, meaning
they set the grass on fire.
So you imagine you're hiding in the
grass and then also in their setting the
grass on fire.
Fortunately,
there was little or no wind and the
grass was too short and too green to burn
well else.
This new weapon might have proved
formidable indeed. The fire,
however,
raised a blue curtain of smoke forming
a corner segment between the fighting
arcs failing in their attempt
to raise a great fire.
The red skins used this smoke line as
a mask for their rifles advancing under
cover of this curtain. They would
pour a volley at our line and retreat.
A little bit of cover move happening.
Our men soon discovered the dodge
and laid equal claim to the curtain.
The Indians abandoning this
position began to draw in their men.
Now general Custer said to Captain
Moylan led us mount and drive them off.
The men immediately mounted in
advanced as skirmishers on a trot.
Finding this was not fast enough.
A charge was ordered.
The men eager for the order gave a loud
yell and put their horses and do a full
gallop.
Nearly 300 number.
The site of 80 cavalry
men coming toward them,
like mad caps was too
much for the Indians.
They turned like sheep and
scattered in every direction.
Battles, battles on the
planes, small unit tactics.
Very similar to the small unit
tactics that are used today.
Throw [inaudible] we use smoke,
you smoking in Ramadi, throw smoke.
We had smoke grenades.
What do you use those for?
Set up a little curtain so people
can't see you when you're moving.
Hmm.
And you'll notice also there
were some aggressive action.
It's that aggressive action. Both,
both sides. When they got aggressive,
they started doing better. When
you start getting, when the other,
when your opponent becomes the aggressor,
you start getting put on your heels.
Just gonna stay aggressive.
Default mode.
Now, uh, talking a little bit about what
it was like when they were back in camp.
So they weren't on the road all the time.
They weren't out in the plains all the
time. Sometimes they'd be back in camp.
They had there, they had bams, they had,
some of them had their wives there. Uh,
they had good food and you know,
basically good stuff going on.
They had pretty relaxed time,
but it was always,
let's prepare.
We're going back out in the field so
they're back out in the field here.
General Custer who has used,
was writing ahead with a couple of troops,
came upon smoldering campfires that showed
the three Indian teepees had recently
been there. He sent bloody knife ahead
with several Indian, so that bloody knife,
you're gonna hear his
voice throughout here.
Bloody knife was costers right hand
man. He was, he was an Indian Scout.
Hmm.
Soon the Gallup back with the information
that they had located the Indians
Custer's surrounded the little camp and
brought back four bucks with him to our
camp.
The head was a minor chief named one Stapp
who squad was a daughter of red cloud
costs or promised them
food if they helped him.
But they seem to be in a hurry to
leave and before they could be checked,
they mounted their ponies and we're off.
Custer's sent troopers after them,
but the only one they could catch
and bring back was one stab.
He was told he would
be given all the bacon,
sugar and coffee that two ponies
could carry if he'd act as a guide.
He agreed.
So, uh, again,
I guess the reason I wanted to bring
that up is it shows that those Indians
working on both sides and it was Indians
that went from w back and forth between
sites, depending on, you know,
depending on what the situation is,
depending on how they got
bribed. But, and also, you know,
we know that there was wars
between the Indians, you know,
so that's why sometimes the Indians
teamed up with the soldiers,
the American troops and went and got
after it with them. Yeah, it is that,
is that because they got,
when you say bribe,
like they got kind of enticed
with civilization? Well, no,
I'm talking about as a
straight up bribe right there.
They're talking to one stab and they say,
Hey, one step, will you help guide us?
Well, I don't know if I feel
comfortable at that. Okay,
we'll give you all the bacon,
all the sugar,
and all the coffee that you can carry on
two horses. He says, all right, cool, Huh?
Yeah.
And if they're warring,
you know that if that's kind of their
enemy and Elaine, right. You know? Yeah,
let's do it. Yeah. Maybe he was
just, maybe he was just getting, uh,
getting some food out of what he
would have already liked to do. Yeah.
And what is it that the enemy of my
enemy is my friend. There you go.
There you go. Now in the black hills,
they think that they find gold.
They think they find gold and the
black hills, and this was just a good,
a good common here about,
I guess you could say it's
about material desires.
Gold to most men means sudden wealth,
big times,
whiskey and gambling and women,
it means fortune and adventure
and all the things they never had.
The gold fever is like taking dope.
You're helpless when it strikes you.
Careful that you know that material greed.
I once read about how everyone who touched
an Egyptian kings tomb was doomed to
die.
A violent death.
Seems to me that the Indians must have
put some curse like that on the white men
who first touched their sacred
black hills. At this time,
Custer got a lot of notoriety from his
black hills expedition and the discovery
gold,
but he never had any luck after that.
Okay,
now
we're getting just a cursory look at the
politics of what were happening at the
time.
An attempt was made that summer of 75
to buy the black hills from the Indians
and make legal this on slot,
but the Indians were no mood to believe
anything the commissioners told them and
it was impossible to make a deal of any
kind of feeling of utter despair and
despondency cast its spell over.
Even the friendly reservation Indians,
maybe the radical thing sitting bull and
crazy horse and Gaul and two moons in
the other wild chiefs far back in the
buffalo lands around the powder and the
big horn we're preaching.
Maybe they made sense.
The free Indian was doomed. They were
all to be made reservation Indians.
That meant all the colorful
old life would be gone forever.
The buffalo hunts, the feasts,
the sun dances, the visiting,
and the pleasant horse stealing wars.
All of the old life would be no more.
Maybe those radical chiefs were right.
Maybe they'd all be better to make
one big battle against the whites.
It would be better to die a free Indian
then live as a degraded helpless treaty.
Indian.
So evident was the hostile feeling that
in the fall of 1875 that an order was
submitted by the Commissioner
of Indian affairs, Edward P.
Smith to the secretary of
the interior xe Chandler,
who interned submitted to the
secretary of war general Belknap.
Subsequent communication from
the secretary of Interior
to the secretary of war
dated December 1st,
1875 read as follows.
I have the honor to inform you that I
have this day directed the commissioner of
Indian affairs to notify said Indian
sitting bull and the others outside their
reservations that they must return to
the reservations before January 31st,
1876 and if they neglect
or refuse so to move,
they will be reported to the war
department as hostile Indians and that a
military force will be sent to compel
them to obey the order of the Indian
department.
Okay.
There it is to compel them.
Yup.
There it is and how you
know that's that's that
you have to be wary of your
government having so much power.
Yeah.
And leaving yourself
defenseless in these situations.
I think we learned a lot from the Indians,
from the native Americans on that.
Back to the book general Custer was not
at four Abraham Lincoln when we arrived
there in late April,
1876 of course that arouse
a lot of talk and suspicion.
When you juggled all those rumors down,
you got about this.
We were soon to start a big expedition
up to Yellowstone to round up the
hostiles and drive them back to the
reservations if they would not go
peacefully,
we were to make good Indians out of them.
There was a lot of suspicious talk
going around all over the place.
Custer was still in the east,
so Custer had gone back to the east and
you could hear a hundred tales of how he
was being kept away from the expedition
because he had got under the skin of
president grant.
A lot of,
a lot of the troopers
didn't much care for Custer,
but it looked as if major reno would
command the regimen if custard didn't
arrive and most of us didn't know or
care a great deal about Reno. Of course,
we knew that he had been a kernel of a
Pennsylvania Cavalry Regiment at the end
of the civil war,
but he had never fought Indians and
he didn't seem to be very popular with
either the men or the officers.
If I remember correctly,
he was a west pointer and was three or
four years ahead of Custer who was pretty
clear that there wasn't much
love lost between the two men,
politics, total politics, and some of
those people in the civilian world,
they don't realize this stuff happens
all the time. It was politics,
crazy politics in the military, and
then just this kind of stuff right here.
Oh your senior to me.
Oh you,
you made the other guy mad and now we're
going to get pulled over to pull you
off this operation. I'm going to
let this guy go on the operation.
This is just so typical of the military,
unfortunately.
And you know what, it's not just simple.
The military, it's typical in any company,
any business,
any team.
There's always going to be these political
things that are happening. I mean,
occasionally you get to a great
organization that really limits that.
I shouldn't say it's everywhere, but
it's very, very common. And you know,
someone just asked me on Twitter,
you know, hey, it's really political.
I'm not really good at at politics,
you know,
which is it something that I should
actually try and engage in and yes,
yes. It's going to, you have to,
if you're in an organization that's a
political organization and you want to
make things happen, you want
to implement changes. Yes.
Start figuring out how to play
those games. Oh, you don't.
You're not a political person.
Cool.
Become one because of what you want
to do is you want to do a good job.
You want to, you want to do good job
and whatever it is that you're doing,
and sometimes that requires that you
play those games. So play the Games,
get good at them.
Back to the book,
everything was uncertain in those
late April and early May days,
while the regiment was being whipped into
marching shape. We had a few recruits,
a bunch,
and a bunch of fresh young horses,
so there was plenty to do
to break in both of them.
One thing that people get wrong about
the recruits was that about half of the
hundred and 50 new men we had were men
who either had civil war experience or
had already served a five
year hitch in the army.
Most of the rest were plenty green,
a good many of them were German boys.
They made fine soldiers.
Once they were trained,
I think it was about May 10th that
general costs are suddenly showed up.
General Terry's with him. Terry was
of slight build and war whiskers.
He was a gentle kindly man who never
struggled her ward, nothing at all.
Like the quick moving dashing young Custer
Terry was a brigadier general of the
regular army and so he
ranked Custer by two grades.
Word ran around camp. The General Terry
was to command the whole expedition,
but the Koster was to
have his old regimen.
Costa was as happy as a
boy with a new red sled.
He put a lot of zip into us now coster
this political stuff that he's dealing
with, um, it's still going on.
It's still happening and I'm not
going to go through the details of it,
but he who somehow seen as a,
as an agitator or an
enemy of president grant,
and so we actually gets ordered
off the two. He goes back out,
takes back over the regiment,
starts whipping people into shape.
He's going to work for General Terry
Grant. President grant says, no,
actually come back. You're
not, you don't get to do this.
And Koester decides he writes a dispatch
to be sent directly to the president of
United States.
It's kind of crazy.
We didn't do much communications with
the president from my task lists.
Here we go back to the book
and the, Oh wait, here's,
so here's what he actually sent.
Is that awesome?
That's what's beautiful about history.
This is what are actually sent and grant
grant president grant was a guy that
was, you know, went to west point as well.
He fought in the Mexican American war.
He retired after that,
retired from the army,
but then the civil war started,
so he went back in the army as a general
and he fought at Shiloh and Vicksburg
and actually general surrendered,
surrendered to
President Grant. So this guys, you know,
a warrior and here's what you're going
to hear. Custer kind of appeal to that.
Hmm.
Here we go.
I have seen your order transmitted
through the general of the army directing
that I not be permitted to accompany
the expedition about to move against the
hostile Indians as my entire regiment
forms a part of the proposed expedition
and as I am the senior officer of the
regimen on duty in the department,
I respectfully but most
earnestly request that I,
while not allowed to go and
command of the expedition,
I may be permitted to serve
with my regimen in the field.
I appeal to you as a soldier to spare
me the humiliation of seeing my regimen
marched to meet the enemy and
I not to share. It's dangerous.
It was too much for the Herro.
The hero of App Apple Modix Custer
was to have back his beloved regimen.
So grant gives in and
says, okay, you can go,
you're not going to be in charge,
but you can go.
And so they roll out on this expedition
and here's the description of what that
felt like.
You felt like you were somebody when
you were on a good horse with a car,
been dangling from its small leather ring
socket on your saddle and a Colt Army
revolver strapped on your hip and a
hundred rounds of ammunition and your web
belt and your saddle pockets.
You were a cavalry men
of the seventh regiment.
You are part of a proud outfit that had
a fighting reputation and you were ready
for a fight or a frolic.
So these guys had some pretty
good morale rolling out.
They did some hard training when they
were in camp and now they're ready to get
after. It talks a little bit about Costa.
He describes Costa,
I can almost see him
myself in my mind's eye.
He was wearing a broad western hat
with a low crown and a wide brand brim.
It was grayish and color.
He'd had his long yellow
hair cut just before we left.
And he had on a buckskin suit with fringe.
He had two short bill barreled,
bulldog revolvers and a Remington
sporting rifle carried in a scabbard.
It's my recollection that he carried a
hunting knife in a fringed buck skin case.
So, uh, that's, I mean, you know,
straight up rock and roll stars of
the 70s war fringe on their outfits.
Right. So Costa was a, he's
a, he's a character, right?
He's definitely a character.
Back to the book, when the regiment
was formed in Kansas in 1866,
the general that went,
the general went to a lot of trouble
to have each troop mounted on distinct
colors. I thought this was
awesome. So I included it.
He's talking about what color horses
they had and each troop had a,
had a specific colored horse,
I can still call them off
even at this late date.
H my own troop road blood bays,
B,
d I n l also were mounted on bays.
C,
G and K had Searles a had Cole
blacks and Lieutenant Edge Lilly's.
Each troop had graze.
We used to call e the band box.
Troop m troop was the only
truth that had mixed colors.
The whole band road,
white horses.
I remember the drummer had a horse that
would run away every time he mounted him,
except when he put his drum on it.
Then that old horse would
stand still as a wooden horse.
It was a fine regiment right enough.
And it wasn't a man in it who didn't
believe it was the greatest cavalry outfit
in the entire United States army.
That, that, that actually is when I,
when I hear about these guys
talking about the horses,
we actually had little relationships
like that with our Humvees.
We'd name them. Yeah. We named our
Humvees. Yeah. We named our Humvees,
various names. Uh, we used to have,
when we used to do a lot more water
work before the war started, we would,
we actually named our outboard
motors and they had little by, uh,
one of my, the guy that handled the
outboard motors in my second platoon.
He was all into it. And, uh,
his nickname was Zulu, Zulu.
He was all into these motors and he had,
every motor had a name and he kept these
detailed bog books on how many hours
and when the maintenance was done,
all that.
And when we came back from one deployment
and we were going to go do another
deployment, we came back, they said, hey,
you know, you guys, guess what? Good News.
We got all new motors and we're
going to issue you. Whatever it was.
We had an eight outboard
motors. Yeah. Hey,
well we're gonna give you all
new mood or at motors, you know,
common turn yours in and we'll
send those off to wherever.
Get repaired are going to go into the
garbage can. And you know, it was lucid.
He said, I want the new motors. I got
my motors. I know where they've been.
I know their personalities. The
voters have personalities. Well,
the motors at personalities and motor
analogies. Yeah, they had personalities.
Yeah. Motor nowadays. And
he wanted to make sure he had a
relationship with those motors.
And you want to give them up.
Going back to the book, they're,
they're starting to be out on patrol.
And they're marching up
what's called the Rosebud
h and the five remaining troops headed
down the powder and eventually arrived at
the southern bank of the Yellowstone.
The wagons had a tough time and it
wasn't until Costa had taken a troop and
scouting out a good road that
the heavy wagons could make it.
Custer was mighty good
at this kind of work.
He had a nose for scouting
and finding the best trails.
It was June.
It was.
It was noon on June 22nd when we
broke camp and started our march up.
The Rosebud.
Yeah.
This just before we packed our mules,
Benton ordered us to take
an extra supply of salt.
That meant we might be living on mule
or a horse meat before we got back.
I suppose we all knew by this time
that we'd be hitting it into dangerous
country,
but as I look back,
I don't believe many
troopers were very worried.
We knew there'd be some hard fighting,
but a soldier always feels that it's
the other fellow who's going to get it.
Never himself that morning word spread
about the camp that mail was going to be
sent back home and that this would likely
be the last chance to get off letters.
Of course,
I didn't have anybody to write too,
but the officers in many of the men
hurriedly scribbled letters to their dear
ones
and as I go to mail off these letters,
they are on a boat.
The troops are on a boat and they barely
gone 50 feet with these letters to get
a mailed off.
When the boat was overturned and all
three men disappeared along with the mail
sack.
Now here's the orders that they'd
go get as they're going up.
These are actually the
orders to Custer and again,
what's awesome is these are documented.
This isn't the hearsay.
These are documented orders.
Colonel,
the brigadier general commanding directs
that as soon as your regiment can be
made ready for the march,
you proceed up the Rosebud in pursuit
of the Indians who's trailed was
discovered by major reno a few days since
it is of course impossible to give you
any definite instructions
in regard to this movement.
And we're not impossible to do.
So.
The department commander places too
much confidence in your zeal energy and
ability to wish to impose on
you precise orders pretty.
So he's giving them,
hey look,
here's my general idea is give
them some commanders in tent,
but he doesn't want to give them
anything too specific because he knows he
can't.
He hasn't always going to be in two days
what's going to be happening up there.
He will,
however,
indicate to you his own views of what
action should be and desires that you
should conform to them unless you should
see sufficient reason for departing
from them.
So he gives him his orders,
but he gives them some pretty
good leeway to work through.
And that's why there's some,
there's some discussion on
whether or not custard disobeyed
and there's a,
it's a,
it's a long discussion probably with
no one could ever come with a solid
conclusion on because there was some,
there was definitely some,
some leeway in the orders and those
that was the leeway that I just read.
Then the orders continue to go on,
but I'm not going to go into
those minor details of them.
Back to the book. We hit the trail at
five o'clock sharp that second morning.
These guys are up pretty early.
Probably had to get up like,
I dunno,
four 30 to get before the to get to get
on the road before five o'clock around
noon we began past signs of big Indian.
As I remember we made
around 33 miles that day.
Okay.
The next day we rode hard to,
there was no foolishness.
Custer had a bunch of re and crow
scout's ahead with him and he kept them
covering the ground far off
both flanks of the column.
We were in Indian country now. Right
enough. So that's, that's very common.
We'd still do that today.
You have a main element moving in a in
a formation and out on the flanks or
maybe some high ground.
You have other smaller elements that can
protect your flanks and see if there's
any problems up ahead.
In one place, we halted,
there had been a sun dance lodge.
Okay.
The scalp of a white man was
still hanging from the ridge pole
getting into Indian country.
It was around eight o'clock
when we got orders to saddle up,
we marched about 10 miles when we
were halted in a sort of ravine.
We've been told to make as little
noise as possible in light. No fires.
There'd been no bugle calls for a
day or two. The Sun was at our back,
so apparently we were headed straight
west. Now toward the little big horn,
I later learned that the Indians called
it greasy grass. I never did know why.
Yeah.
About the time.
General Custer came back from his scout
word run around that the Indians had
found a box of hardtack that had dropped
from one of Captain Yates is mules,
two or three troopers who had
been sent back to pick up the box,
had reported seeing two hostels trying
to open it with their Tomahawks.
This meant that the Indians held us,
had us under observation.
Okay.
Apparently custard figured on hiding
the command in the ravine during the day
and then attacking the big Indian village
on the little big horn at daybreak the
next morning.
So there, there, there,
yeah.
They know that the Indians
know that they're there.
This is why I included that.
Then you're going to hear that
kind of over and over again.
Custer's thinking they're
going to surprise him and
everyone's telling him we're
not going to surprise them. They know
we're here. It was Sunday morning,
June 25th we were still more than 12
miles from the little horn and the Indian
village, but the Indians knew
where we were and all about us.
Okay.
I approached,
I approached as near that now.
So there he,
he's a conversation going on and it's
actually coster and Ben teen and they're
having a conversation with a couple of
people including some of the scouts and
he kind of goes over and does a
little ease dropping as I approached,
as near as seemed respectful.
And while I was waiting to
catch Ben Teens attention,
I couldn't help but overhear part of
the conversation. Charlie Reynolds,
the famous white scout who is never to
see the sunset that day was talking.
And I heard him say that there was the
biggest bunch of Indians he'd ever seen
over there. Finally I heard.
But venting state Acosta hadn't.
We better keep the regiment together
general if this is a big camp,
as they say,
we'll need every man we have.
Custer's only answer was
you have your orders.
So you can see again, [inaudible]
ease, not listening to people,
Scouts,
reconnaissance units and his
other officers that are with him.
And this is sort of the classic,
you know, Hey, I've got a,
I've got an I disagree with your plan.
Shut up and do it anyways.
You have your orders.
That's a classic example of that.
Okay.
We were tired and dirty and hungry or
horses hadn't had a good drink of water
since the day before and
we weren't much better off.
We knew right enough that
this was the day, this was it.
This was what we'd been training
and working for all these years.
Captain Benton used to say,
the government pays you to get
shot at and I suppose the dumbest,
greenest trooper and the regimen figured
that this day he'd get shot at plenty.
Here was the seventh cavalry with a
total of some 600 men split up into four
outfits.
Apparently the Indian scouts
and experienced old guys guides knew
that there were several thousand of the
hostels,
but it was,
it is my belief that cost her and most
of our officers thought they'd have to
whip somewhere between 1,015 hundred
and they expected most of these to be
poorly armed and poorly
led from experience.
They figured the Indians would fight
only a rear guard action while the women,
children,
old men and pony herds got away.
But in place of a maximum of 1500
Indian warriors, it developed it.
There were possibly twice that number
about to face costers total of 600
so that's the report that they're getting.
And
there's a little bit of
controversy about what,
how many Indians were there, but it
was a lot. And here, here we go. This,
I'm going to jump forward to another
section and talking about Custer and did
cost her. The name of the chapter is
did Koster and it's sort of a appendix,
so it's not part of the story, it's
after the story, but it talks about,
did Costa refuse advice from his scouts?
How many Indian warriors were camped
on the West Bank of the little big horn
that Sunday morning of June
25th against the real figure,
how many customers think
he would have to fight?
Did customer refuse to believe
the estimated number of warriors?
Has Scouts told him he
would have to fight?
Did he fail to follow the advice of his
experienced guides? And interpreters.
One of the best accounts of what the
guides thought about the number of Indians
and the chances of Custer closing with
them is contained in the excellent book.
William Jackson Indian scout
by James William Schulz,
Willard shots.
It is worth careful reading and
here's a couple of excerpts from that.
On the third day we struck
the trail of the hostels,
the one that Reno had found several
days before said bloody knife.
Now remember bloody knife is is customers,
you know main scout there,
they're tight said bloody knife.
My friends,
the big this big tree
trail proves what we heard.
Okay,
that the Ogallala,
the Miniconjou,
the sand Sark and the Teton sue have
left their agencies to join sitting bull
and crazy horse horse.
I'm sure that even this trail does not
account for all that have left their
agencies.
There surely are other trails and trails
to of the Cheyennes and the Arapahos
bloody knife continued.
It is as I have told long hair,
this gathering of enemy
tribes is too many for us,
but he will not believe me.
He is bound to lead us against them.
They are not far away
just over this ridge.
They are all in Campton waiting for us
crazy horse and sitting bull are not men
without,
since they have their scouts too and some
of them surely have their eyes upon us.
Well tomorrow we are
going to have a big fight,
a losing fight myself.
I know what is to happen to me.
My sacred helper has given me warning
that I am not to see the set of tomorrow's
son.
Okay.
Sad words.
Those they chilled us.
I saw Charlie Reynolds nod in agreement
to them and was chilled again when he
said in a low voice.
I feel as he does tomorrow
will be the end for me too.
Okay.
Anyone who wants my little outfit of
stuff pointing to his war pack can have it
now.
Lieutenant Varnum who is in charge of
the scouts came over and said that it was
general Koster's plan to attempt a
surprise attack on the camp of the enemy.
Okay.
Said bloody knife. We cannot surprise
the enemy. They are not crazy.
Yeah.
Without DME,
without doubt,
their scouts have watched
every move we have made.
Okay.
Convinced at last that we could
not possibly surprise the enemy.
General Custer ordered a quick advance
with the scouts and himself in the lead.
Okay.
We had not gone far when bloody knife
and his to RISD joined us and reported
that on the other side of the ridge
they had found the day old trail of many
more enemy going toward the
valley of little big horn.
They were excited and
said to cost or general.
We have discovered the camp down
there on the little big horn.
It is a big one too big for you to tackle.
Why?
There are thousands and thousands of
Sioux and Cheyenne is down there for a
moment.
That general stared at him angrily I
thought and then said sternly I shall
attack them.
Classic Ego Maniac right here.
Sorry, but that's what this is.
Yeah.
Coster gave orders for attack upon the
camp. None of the scouts had been foreign.
The lead and they all came in.
Reason Crows and whites and Robert and I,
we were a gathering of solemn faces
speaking in English and the sign language
too so that all would understand.
Brewer described them, the enemy camp,
it was,
he said all of three miles long
and made up of hundreds of lodges,
hundreds and hundreds of lodges
above it and below it and west of it.
There were thousands and thousands
of horses that were being close,
hurted with his few riders.
Long hair decided to attack the camp and
we were going to have a terrible fight.
We should all take courage, fight
hard, make our every shot a killer.
He finished and none spoke.
But after a minute or two,
bloody knife looked up
and signed to the sun.
I shall not see you go down
behind the mountains tonight.
And at that I almost choked.
I felt he knew his end was near
and there was no escaping it.
I turned and looked the other way.
I thought that my own end was near.
I felt very sad.
So there's the full account of these.
All the scouts, some are, you know,
some are white, some are Indian,
native Americans, different tribes, and
they're all telling them the same thing.
This is not a good plan.
Yeah.
So back to the book,
apparently cost her head planned
to stay in hiding in the ravine.
We had reached a little after 10 o'clock
that Sunday and then attack the village
at daybreak the next morning of the 26
that would more or less of dovetailed
into Terry's idea of boxing the Indians.
But when he found the hostile
scouts had discovered his column,
he figured there was nothing
to do but attack at once.
Now we get a little,
um,
a little report here from a guy named
Sergeant Daniel [inaudible] who had barely
turned 23 at the time of the battle
in canapes own account of the fight
published in the magazine of the
Historical Society of Montana.
He said, when we got to the top of the
bluffs, the Indians had disappeared,
but we were in plain
view of the Indian camps,
which appeared to cover a space of about
two miles wide and four miles long on
the west side of the river.
We were then charging it full speed.
This camp is two miles wide. That's
a mat. Two miles, two by four,
two by four miles,
and you've got 600 guys.
I actually didn't even cost it
doesn't have 600 guys to get 200 guys.
Yeah.
Reno and his troops were again seen to
our left moving at full speed down the
valley at the site of the Indian camps.
The boys of our five troops
began to cheer overconfidence.
Hmm.
Some of the horses became so excited
that the writers were unable to hold them
in ranks.
And the last word I heard general Custer
say we're hold your horses in boys.
There are plenty of them down
there for all of us. Again,
now we have total overconfidence in the
situation. We think we're going to win.
This is going to be fun. Oh,
there's two by four mile big camp.
No big deal.
I got 500 guys with me.
So this is where the force is split up
and Costa goes off to attack any good.
It seems like he goes about a mile
away, mile and a half away. And again,
I'm going to make the same statement that
I said when I talked about the battle
with w w when we did
the wooden leg podcast.
I'm not trying to re historically
reconstruct a battle right now.
There's plenty of books that do that,
so I'm just kind of assembling the
broad design of what's happening.
Yeah.
So now the forest is split up a reno
and venting or kind of have troops and
holding, but they're starting to get
in a little firefight themselves.
We saw a second figure in uniform
riding towards us. He was Trump,
a tier Martini of my company who had
been assigned that morning as a special
orderly Trump a to general Custer.
I learned afterwards that he had a
message from or to Ben teen that had been
scribbled out on a field order
pad and signed by Lieutenant Cook,
the adjutant it read Ben Teen.
Come on,
big village, be quick. Bring packs.
Ps bring pack.
Okay.
That's the note that they get from Custer.
Sounds like customer might might've.
Uh, once he split off, things
started going sideways real quick.
They
again, Ben Teen and and Reno have their
troops start now getting engaged in a
firefight. Back to the book we
could hear heavy firing now.
Before long we passed several cro or
re scouts driving a few heads of Indian
ponies and they shouted soldiers and
pointed toward the bluffs that were rising
towards the north.
We knew that we were close to the valley
of little big horn and that somewhere
in this neighborhood there
was hard fighting going on.
Benton ordered us to draw pistols and
we charged up the bluffs that a gallop
expecting at any moment
to run into hostels.
When we reached the brow of
the first set of rolling hills,
the river valley suddenly
opened up below us to our left.
It was a sight to strike terror in the
hearts of the bravest men down there in
the valley,
maybe 150 feet or more below us and
somewhere around a half a mile away there
were figure scalloping on horseback and
much shooting farther down the river.
There were great masses of mounted men.
We suspicioned we're Indians.
We were going at it at
a fast clip ourselves,
and we had no more than caught the
swift glimpse of this tragic battlefield
below.
When we saw mounted and
dismounted soldiers on a
knoll of a hill onto the north
ward,
we swiftly road towards them.
So these guys are seeing this
massive battle take place.
They're kind of on the high ground.
He talks about here what kind of weapon
tree the the Indians had for my part.
I believe that fully half of the
warriors carried only bows and arrows and
lances and that possibly half of the
remainder carried odds and end of old
muzzle loaders and single shot
rifles of various vintages.
Probably not more than 25 or 30% of the
warriors carried modern repeating rifles.
That sounds pretty close
to what would leg said.
They said they mostly had bows and
arrows. Nate, some guys had rifles,
but it was mostly bows and arrows and
one other port Indian boys from 14 years
old up accompanied the
warriors and took part,
especially in the later stages of the
fighting the soldiers. Incidentally,
we're armed with single shot 45 70 caliber
Springfield carbines and accurate and
deadly wrapping up to 600 yards,
but when fired rapidly,
the breach became foul and the
greasy cartridges often jammed.
It could not be removed by the extractor.
This meant that the empty shell had to
be forced out by the blade of a hunting
knife.
This very fact was responsible for the
death of many a trooper this hot Sunday
and may actually have been the
indirect cause of the great disaster
weapons, getting dirty
weapons, getting hot and dirty,
got to take care of your weapon.
It sounds like this was a beyond them
just taking care of their weapon. Right.
Sounds like it was a design issue as well.
Yeah.
Renew had crossed the river and had his
troops in line of columns of four with
the Indian,
with the Indian scouts on his left.
Soon Indian horsemen were seen writing
madly to and fro in the valley and
shortly the southern end of the
Indian camps came into Reno.
Now had his three troops and scouts
thrown out in a skirmish line covering
possibly the full width
of the narrow valley.
So there they see the enemy. Now they
get online. That's a very common thing.
If you can picture this, you've got your
guys in a column. How many, if we are,
if you're in a column of
three, three columns and you
see the enemy ahead of you,
how many people do think can shoot the
three, the three, the three in the front.
So that's why you keep hearing this,
this idea of a skirmish line and it's
the same tactic that we use now. Oh,
we got enemy in front of us.
Cool. We're going to get online.
They call it a skirmish line here. We
would call it a get online. Like they'll,
they're spread out red on one. Yup. So
now they get, they got 50 guys cold.
I have 50 guns online instead of three.
Yeah.
Realizing that this charge toward the
Indian hordes would end in almost certain
disaster. Reno now ordered his
troops to dismount and fight on foot.
Even before this order came,
scores of Indians had swung to the south
westward and pressed against the cro
and re scouts.
These were forced to give way.
Things were looking bad for Reno and he
ordered a skirmish lines to fall back to
the edge of a heavy grove of cottonwoods
that followed a bend in the river and
jutted out halfway across the valley,
the horses were led into the woods while
a thin line of men held three sides of
the Grove,
some 90 men were holding not
less than 250 yards of line,
hundreds of mounted Indians.
We're now half circling the skirmish line,
riding in close, firing from under their
ponies next and then galloping away.
Reno's men were now either firing from
a prone position or using the bank of a
dry creek bed as a
barricade and rifle rest.
So Reno's guys are now getting basically
surrounded in taking up this new
position. Sergeant O'hara
of troop m had been killed.
The first man on the skirmish line to die.
Apparently Reno had a fairly defendable
position and some people think if he had
pulled in his lines and
consolidated his position,
he might've held out here for
an indefinite length of time,
or at least as long as his ammunition
lasted. But the savage yells,
the heavy firing,
the smoke and dust all and fear
all combined to fog his judgment.
Suddenly Custer's favorite scout bloody
knife was shot through the head and his
brain scattered all over Reno.
Then the Scout Dorman fell and Charlie
Reynolds was shot through the head Reno
figuring that his only chance lay in
getting to high ground across the river,
shouted for his men to mount
up and company formation
to troop commanders heard
the order and amid the confusion and
excitement had their men mount up and line
and column of force.
The third troop g under lieutenant
Macintosh himself, part Indian,
who had been adopted by General Mcintosh,
was in the woods and did not get the
order until the two other troops with Reno
riding at their head.
We're racing upstream trying to
find a place to cross the river.
All order and discipline were gone.
So they're surrounded, things fall apart.
He's basically saying, we got to retreat,
we gotta get Outta here.
And the assessment was that maybe
they were in a defendable position.
They could have held there, but who knows?
Who knows whether that's true or not.
Nobody will ever know how any man
escaped alive from this mad retreat.
All we are sure of is that the charging
troop broke through the cordon of
mounted Indians and followed a
buffalo Prath to the river here.
They somehow manage to jump their
horses over a four or five foot bank,
plunge across the stream and scramble
up a narrow trail to the steep hills,
to the east,
hundreds of Indians fired indiscriminately
into the panic stricken soldiers.
And the wonder is that
any trooper escaped,
no motion picture could be as fantastic
as this wild milling of frightened men
and horses.
Okay.
Again, just to remind you that this is
what's happening with Reno and his group.
They don't know where Costa is
right now with his crew of 200 guys
back to the book in all 26 troopers in
scouts and three officers were killed
either in this ride through the Indian
gauntlet or back at the edge of the woods
of the 19 men left behind 17 cross the
river and reached Reno Hill on foot
within two hours.
Lieutenant Wdo and private O'Neil
did not join us until 36 hours later.
They came right through
where I was on guard.
It was now somewhere around
three 30 in the afternoon.
Reno Shaken and unnerved had reached
the hilltop and hear his frightened
troopers.
We're joining him.
He was whipped and
completely disorganized.
This is a rally point and if you have a
predesignated rally point and you say,
hey guys, look, you see this big hill
over here. If everything goes to hell,
can we get all jumbled up?
Go to that point.
It doesn't sound like he
actually pre-brief that
cause that would have been a,
you could've just said, hey,
back to the rally point.
You could have given a very clear order
if you're trying to not really know
where you're going and you're saying
retreat while you don't do it in a very
organized fashion.
So preplan some contingencies.
Hmm.
Now they get in this position and Reno,
like I said, is in rough shape. Back
to the book. Cool, capable Ben teen,
more or less assumed command major Rooney
Reno had just come through a terrible
experience and at the moment was glad
to have Ben teen, his junior takeover,
quickly venting,
dismounted his own three troops and
ordered us to form a skirmish line.
Reno's men had expended
most of their ammunition.
So we were told to divide ours with them.
We had Ben Teens,
hundred and 20 men intact,
and there were around 60 men who'd
been fighting in the valley with Reno.
And even before we got the kinks out of
our legs from our long horse hours in
the saddle, we were asking
each other, where's Custer,
what had become of Custer
and his five troops?
Apparently Custer was now much farther
on to the north ward and in this moment
was hotly engaged,
but no one was certain.
All we knew was that he had disappeared
with almost half the regiment.
We could hear the sound of distant firing
echoing through the hills and valleys
from that direction.
Customer must be down there.
So this is happening there in the skirmish
position and they're starting to try
and get reorganized back to the book.
The wounded men who could
mount were put on horses,
but the others were carried in blankets
by details of six troopers on foot.
It takes a lot of people to carry it down,
man down man.
man,
and in this case it takes six
people to carry one down. Man.
Nowadays we weigh a lot more.
We got, we got all of our guns,
we got body armor. It's hard.
Guys are heavy. Pretty soon
it looked as if the Indian
masters were coming towards us.
It didn't take long to realize
that this was true here.
We were stretched out all over hell's
half Acre a troop. On this hill mob,
another in this little valley
and a third and over there,
a third troop behind at a slow walk came
packed trains the wounded men and the
rear guard reno inventing both sense
danger and order to withdrawal.
The advanced troops were dismounting
and fought as skirmishers in the center.
In a slight depression,
the horses and mules were staked and
an inadequate little field hospital was
established,
but it was impossible to shield the men
and stock from the Indians firing from a
hilltop off to the east. Indians got
some high ground on him. Can't stop them.
What do you do? They got to high
ground you. You can't hide animal.
After animals killed and the men were hit,
it was tough not to be able
to do something about it.
We'd hardly got settled on
our own skirmish line with
age men posted at 20 foot
intervals when the Indians and all but
completely surrounded us and the fighting
begin in earnest.
There was no full fledged charge,
but little groups of Indians would
creep up as close as they could get.
And for behind bushes or
little nose open fire,
they'd practiced all kinds of
cute tricks to draw our fire.
Maybe a naked redskin would suddenly
jumped to his feet and while you drew a
bead on him,
he'd throw himself to the ground.
Okay?
They're under this attack for
a pretty good amount of time.
And then finally the sun went down
that night like a ball of fire.
Pretty soon the quick Montana twilight
settled down on us and then came the
chill of the high plains.
There was no moon and no one ever
welcome darkness more than we did.
We felt terribly alone on
that dangerous hilltop.
We were million miles from nowhere
and death was all around us.
Okay?
All through that Short Black Knight,
the orgy went on down
below in the river valley.
It struck fear in our hearts,
just as the mystery of
Custer's disappearance made
our blood run cold each time
we tried to solve it, where was
coster? What had happened to him?
Okay,
so down there, up there, they're
hiding. It's dark, they're scared,
they got wounded in all they hear down
in the valley as the Indians going crazy.
The rhythm of the Tom Tom's the wild
victory dance. They can hear all this.
Okay,
back to the book. They're talking about
cost or they could not all be killed,
not Lucky Koster and those five
gallon troops who rolled with him,
why did he abandoned us? And those three
bloody hours before dark said, save us.
We had no less than a dozen men killed
and three times that number of wounded.
Okay.
He's actually saying,
man,
where was Custer here we were getting
crushed on the battlefield and cook cost
or is not there to support
us. Where do you go? Hmm.
Now during the night at reigns a little
bit and finally the sun starts to come
up and just as the sun starts to come up,
it starts getting light back to the book.
Joan said something about
taking off his overcoat.
He started to roll on his side so he
could get his arms and shoulders out
without exploding, exposing himself
to fire. Suddenly I heard him cry out.
He'd been shot straight through the heart,
minute or two later,
another bullet from the hilltop,
torn to the Hickory,
but have my rifle
splitting it squarely into,
I was plenty mad because my army carbing
wouldn't let me return the compliment,
so he just got shot.
The rifle stock actually happened.
One of my guys and in Ramadi,
one of my guys got is his rifle stock,
got blown up by an RPG.
I seem come,
fallen out of a sniper
position and he's got his arm.
His weapon is in two pieces.
I'm thinking how lucky to be alive.
Yeah.
Along about this time are 30 or 40
wounded men began crying out for water.
H troop held the hill on the south west.
There was a draw that ran down the
west side of the hill to the river.
It was a rough and exposed and it looked
like a dead cinch that anyone who tried
to work his way down that drug,
the river would be killed.
Indians concealed in the
bushes across the river.
We're firing up at us and they had every
foot of this draw and river riverbank
covered.
Okay.
But we had to do something for those men
who were up wounded, crying for water.
Finally bent [inaudible]
called for volunteers.
Okay.
I think there were 17 of us all
together who stepped forward.
He detailed four of us from h who were
extra good marksmen to take up an exposed
position on the brow of
the hill facing the river.
We were to stand up and not only
draw the fire of the Indians below,
but we were to pump as much lead as we
could into the bushes where the Indians
were hiding while the water
party hurry down to the draw,
got their buckets and pots and canteens
filled and then made their way back.
Yeah,
so we got a little
covering move happening.
Obviously it just happened that the four
of us who were posted on the hill where
all German boys, Geiger
Mechling void, and myself,
none of us for war wounded,
although we stood exposed on that
Ridge for more than 20 minutes and they
through plenty of lead at us.
Several of the water party, however,
were badly wounded.
Although we kept the steady fire into
the bushes where the Indians were hiding,
each of us was given a
congressional medal of honor.
Okay?
You don't think about that.
You don't think about it. You,
you actually going to need water.
You run out of water,
you're going to get guys
dehydrated and a die.
So now you're gonna risk
people's lives to go get water.
Ben Teen had been walking up and down
the line urging men to hold fast,
not to waste their firing, to keep
cool. I remember saying to him, colonel,
you better get down sir. You'll
get killed. Don't worry about me.
He answered grimly I'm all right.
He sure lived a charmed life that day,
but things look bad.
And finally Benton hurried to the north
side of the lines and asked Major Reno
for reinforcements.
He made it clear that the Indians were
about to charge his line and then if they
were able to sweep over it,
the whole outfit would be destroyed.
Reno told him to take as much
of an troupe as he could gather.
Those men certainly look good to us.
Soon after they came up,
Captain Benton led the charge,
yelling and firing.
We went at the double quick
and the Indians broken ran
when we had cleaned them
out for a hundred yards ahead of us. We
hustled back to our holes. Once again,
we settled back to the business of
getting fired at with men hit at intervals
with men hit at intervals and with the
poor horses and mules taking a terrible
beating in their hollow.
It must have been a long time.
About long about this time that Ben
team called me to attention and made me
sergeant.
Okay.
We had one sergeant, two men killed,
and 12 wounded and age tree Palone.
So once again,
we see some and we also see
some focus of forces, right.
We see some prioritize and execute,
hey, we're going to get overrun.
There's our biggest problem right
now is we're going to get overrun.
So you know what?
Hey,
major reno gave me a bunch of guys
and we're going to go do an aggressive
assault and take care of
this number one priority,
so let's focus our forces on that.
Here we go, and that's what they did.
They got aggressive and got after it.
Okay,
back to the book,
the gunfire to almost ceased and some of
us left our trenches and student little
groups on the brow of the hill.
Then something happened that I'll never
forget if I live to be a hundred the
heavy smoke seem to lift for a few
moments and they're in the valley below.
We caught glimpses of the thousands of
Indians on foot and horseback with their
pony hoards with their pony herds,
dogs and pack animals,
and all the trappings of a gay
great camp solely moving southward.
It was like some biblical exodus.
The Israelites moving into Egypt's
a mighty tribe on the march.
We thought at first that it must be some
trick that the Indians were only moving
their families from danger and that the
warriors would soon return and try to
overwhelm us patiently.
We weighed in in our little
trenches the long June afternoon,
dragged on the firing at all,
but ceased the smoke in the valley had
blown away and the last Indian had gone.
Then Reno ordered the whole camp to
move as close to the river as possible.
We would get as far as ways we could
from the terrible stench of death.
There was plenty of water now for
the wounded and towards the evening.
The company cooks made us the
best meal they could. At least.
We had hot coffee and plenty
of Bacon and so card attack.
It was our first meal in 36 hours.
Then night came down.
We were wary, but while those
on guard, we're awake and alert.
The rest of the command slept,
but it was an uneasy sleep.
We still had heard no word from Costa.
We began to suspicion that some terrible
fate might've ope overtaken him.
What it was.
We could only guess.
The Sun was well in the sky that next
morning of the 27th and we saw dust rising
slowly from the valley northward,
so then they get approached
by a young officer.
They'd been out scouting
what was happening.
A young officer flung
himself off his horse.
He was Lieutenant Bradley Chief of Scouts.
Early this morning,
scouting in the hills on the east side,
a little horn lieutenant Bradley had
come across a battlefield dotted with the
white bodies of dead men.
He had counted more than 190 dead.
He was certain that Custer was among them.
Apparently no white man had escaped.
One or two crow scouts.
Notably young curly had reported at the
steam or far west at the junction of
little big and big horn the day before.
There had been no interpreter on hand,
but curly had convinced the officer's
that all white soldiers who rode with
custard had been killed at dawn,
Lieutenant Bradley and
a few men and a few men.
It started out to search for the field
of tragedy. Curly was right. No soldier.
A white man had escaped a little later.
The slight figure of bearded General
Terry with his staff and a small escort
arrived on the hill. There were tears
running down his cheeks when he spoke.
I think most of us had tears in her eyes
to more than 200 of our comrades and
had met a violent death
and now naked on buried.
We're lying in the hot Montana
Cen three miles northward.
Okay,
so they'd go out to recover the bodies
or bury the bodies there on patrol back
to the book.
Suddenly we caught glimpses of white
objects lying along a ridge that led
northward.
We pulled up our horses.
This was the battlefield here.
Custer's La Loche had finally run out.
Okay.
From the way the men lay,
it was clear that the first one troop
had been ordered to dismount and fight as
a skirmish line.
Then a second troop had been posted
a little further on and to the east.
Then a third troop and a fourth,
and finally they're on the Knob of a
hill lace on 30 bodies in a small circle.
We knew instinctively we
would find Custer. There.
We wrote forward at a walk.
Most of the troopers had been
stripped of clothing and scalped.
Some of them had been horribly mutilated.
Custer was lying,
a trifle to the southeast
of the top of the knoll
where the monument is today.
I stood six feet away holding captain
bent teens horse while he identified the
general,
his body had not been touched,
say for a single bullet hole in the left
temple near the ear and a hole on his
left breast. He looked almost as if
it had been piece of we sleeping.
His brother Tom lay a few feet away.
He was terribly mutilated,
scattered over the field where the
swollen bodies of the dead horses,
but there were not many of them.
It seemed clear that the Indians sweeping
up from the draws and Cooley's on all
sides had stampeded the mounts while the
men were fighting dismounted from every
direction.
Hordes of crazed Indians must have
attacked with the wild courage that their
desperation and hate gave them.
Okay.
Nothing could check their mad charges.
Captain Dentine found a bit of wood,
hollowed out a whole,
found an empty shell,
wrote customer's name on a bit of paper
and placed it in the shell and shoved
the deep in hole in a piece of wood.
Then he pushed this into the
ground at customer's head.
He would make sure that the burial
party would identify Custer's body.
The following morning we went back to
Custer hill and buried as well as we could
the naked mutilated
bodies of our comrades.
It was a gruesome task.
Okay.
Custer may have made a mistake to divide
his command that Sunday afternoon of
June 25th but the gods
themselves were against him.
It was the Indians.
Day
eight I'm going to go back to finish this
up to the section of the book that we
started at and that is this account
from major reno who we know a little bit
more about now,
but
I think that the way he wraps it up
and they actually did a massive trial,
a big trial for Reno,
and they found that the actions
that he took were not negligent.
He might've made some calls that might
not have been the best tactical to calls
if you look back on it.
Yeah.
But he,
he was basically cleared
of any wrong doing clearly.
Clearly I think it's pretty clear
that wind off thinks, you know,
he broke and he lost control of his
troops and then Ben teen kind of took over
and got things squared
away. Okay. Clearly,
clearly wind off was also
a huge fan of venting,
so he might be spinning that story
a little bit in that direction.
But I do think that Reno,
I think that him looking back on
the incident and he kind of wraps up
his assessment of what happened
and what went wrong that day.
And also I think for
lack of a better word,
that there is a,
if there's a warning of sorts in this,
so here's Reno.
After much reflection,
I've concluded that several great
blunders where the direct causes of the
[inaudible] massacre,
it is an established fact that Custer
disobeyed the orders of the general in
command of the expedition for instead
of waiting to meet General Gibbon and
General Terry on June 26 at the Rosebud,
and then cooperate with them and their
concerted plan of action as he had been
directed. As soon as he struck
the trail of the Indians,
he followed it until he came upon
the Indian village, June 25th
then without attempting to communicate
with either Terry or given and without
taking the trouble to ascertain the
strength or positions of the Indians,
he divided his regiment into
three separate battalions,
an act which nothing can justify and
dashed against the Indians thus recklessly
driving his own and my commands
into an Ambi SCADE of 5,000 sue,
nor did cost or take into consideration
the unfed and exhausted conditions of
the men and his horses,
and he entirely ignored the fact that the
Indians were key Vva and ready for the
attack at noon.
Whereas it would have been an easy
matter to surprise them very early in the
morning.
The only explanation for such conduct on
the part of so brilliant and officer as
cost are undoubtedly was otherwise,
was his great personal ambition.
He had fought himself partially disgraced
because he had been superseded in
command of the expedition
by General Terry,
and it was well known that
he was resolved, if possible,
to carry off all the honors of the
campaign for being in command of the only
cavalry regiment attached
to the expedition.
He knew the brunt of the fighting
would necessarily fall on him,
and he made it no secret of his intention
to cut loose from Terry where there
was fighting to be due to be done and
to carry on the campaign on his own hook
absolutely insensible.
The fear.
He was so reckless and daring in the
extreme and driven by an intense desire to
distinguish himself by
some brilliant exploit.
He made his head long
dash two a horrible death
without the most causal regard for
the maxims of military prudence.
Even now after the lapse
of nearly 10 years,
the horror of Custer's battlefield is
still vividly before me and the harling
sight of those mutilated and decomposing
bodies crowning the heights on which
poor coster fell will linger in my memory
till death.
And I think that's a pretty clear warning.
And of course there are military lessons
to be learned from this account of the
battle of little big horn.
Maintain the element of surprise.
Keep your forces unified
as much as possible, taken,
maintain the high ground
to rule.
We should always follow trust
your reconnaissance units.
You've got them out there,
listen to them,
make sure your troops are
rested and fed and have water.
But beyond those fundamental
military tactical lessons,
I think it becomes quite clear that there
is a another enemy that we must always
be on the watch for.
Okay,
then that is ego,
our own ego.
We have to keep our ego in check.
You have to watch out for
it and guard against it.
Getting control of view and interfering
with your decision making process.
No,
I always say this.
This doesn't mean that
ego should be banished.
It absolutely has a very
positive side as well.
It drives us to push hard.
It drives us to do our best.
And a guy like Custer who personally
led cavalry charges at the battle of
Gettysburg that were critical in stopping
flanking actions from confederate
troops and an action that no doubt
was fueled by courage and bravery,
but also was fueled at some level by ego
because ego is a driver of our actions
and some times it can be a positive
driver of our actions,
but it has to be balanced,
has to be balanced by humility
in open ears and an open mind.
Keep the ego in check,
Anna,
I'll tell you something else like your
ego on another lesson from this is that
you have to keep your emotions in check.
And you heard the brutality that was
committed in these wars on both sides,
both sides,
anger and fear and frustration.
Those result in an
escalation on both sides.
Okay?
And on both sides there were
truly horrific acts of savagery.
And that's an extreme example.
This whole story is an
extreme example of both those,
both the ego and the emotional.
May Him.
Okay.
That are shown in this
example are very extreme,
but also think about how they
relate toward your every day life,
okay?
How often do you let your ego get in
the way of making the right decision?
How often do you let your
emotions drive your decisions?
How often do you go to war
because of your emotions
and because of your ego?
How often did you go to
a war because of them?
In what I'm saying?
Stop.
Stop doing that.
Get control of your emotions and get
control of your ego and put them in check
so you aren't escalating to situations
where you savage your enemy or your
friends or your coworkers or your
peers or your family or whoever.
You do nothing in those situations
to further your mission in life.
But instead you just distract and
detract from reaching your real goals.
Don't let that happen.
Learn burn from this particular battle.
See what the emotions and ego do.
Okay.
And find a better way.
Deescalate
the build coalitions with people
instead of building blood feuds.
Work with people instead
of working against people.
Lift people up instead
of casting them down.
And in short, what that is, is leading.
That is what true leadership is and
that is what a true leader does.
Okay.
So go out there
and do it.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
Just a,
just a brutal,
brutal situation that this is,
I actually pull up some other quotes too.
In the beginning of the book,
I talk about some of these
massacres that were considered, uh,
committed by the soldiers.
Yeah. In some of these raids.
And this is one right here,
John S.
Smith from his congressional testimony.
This is from the sand creek massacre,
by the way. I saw the bodies of
those lying there cut all the,
okay.
Worst mutilated than
any I ever saw before.
The women cut to pieces with knives
scalped their brains knocked out children
two or three months old.
Okay.
All ages lying there from
sucking infants up to warriors
by whom?
Where they mutilated
by United States troops.
Okay.
In the, again, this might,
my point in bringing that up is that
it's the escalation of emotions and the
escalation of ego.
And I'm going to pay them back.
And we so often drive ourselves to
these situations in everyday life.
I mean obviously not to this scale.
Okay.
But how do we overcome that?
And I think you got to concentrate on
keeping your ego and your emotions in
check. Yeah. Yeah.
And there's also that
slippery slope factor where
like remember the the one I think it was,
I think it was me lie,
where we're talking about the slippery
slope in kind of one thing leads to
another where if you kind of look at the
end, the result, you're like, no way.
I would never do that.
I will never be in that situation.
But it starts like with one little
thing, you know? So from one step to the,
to the next step or the for one little
step where you slide or on the slippery
slope, it's like, that's easy.
You know, where it's like,
all right, one guy gets mad,
he slaps this guy, you know? Or even,
I mean it goes really with
anything with a slippery slope.
Anything like cheating on your
diet, I don't know. It does.
And what we're really talk about is
what's the cure to the slippery slope?
It's the discipline plan.
Yeah.
It's maintaining the discipline is
maintaining the personal discipline.
What you're talking about,
like how it's a slippery slope going
down the doughnut slope. Yeah. Right.
We don't want to do that. But on top of
that, you get into a leadership situation.
Absolutely. It's a slippery slope and
you give that little bit, you think,
you know it's no big deal. I liked that
guy. Hey, he's got, he got a little angry.
That's okay.
But everybody else saw that happen and
now you're just allowing this to happen
and it's only going to escalate.
But it's so I think about this,
think about easy it is to stop
that one thing and say, hey, echo,
what are you doing? Come over here.
Hey look, we don't hit prisoners.
Stop what you're doing. Get it
together. If you're mad, go over there.
Take a breath. Yeah. That's
pretty easy for me to stop.
Now what happens when you shoot
somebody? Now we have, you know,
we have a major incident now
you're going to jail. I mean it's,
it's a totally different thing.
I could've stopped that very
easily in the beginning. Yeah. Or
I can have major issues to deal
with in the end. Yeah. Like this.
I mean this is more of like
the slippery slope situation,
but not war or nothing like that. But you
know how like, I dunno financial guys,
right? They'll, there'll be
like, hey, going to do in Vr,
I don't know, investments. You know, you
hear about this where there'll be like,
okay, I'm going to collect this
money from my, my, you know,
my clients and then I'm going
to invest it. Right. And then,
Hey, I'm just going to grab this little
bit. I'll pay it right back. You know,
next thing you know, you're going to level
seven Ponzi scheme. Yeah. They see that.
And that's the thing that's a
slippery slope where when you start,
even before you like start
to slip or whatever, when
you start your, you think of,
okay,
where am right now and going to prison
for the Ponzi so you never would have no
way I'm going to, you know,
I've seen other guys do.
It sounds like that would really be
the psychology of people that do that.
Like all I bet a lot. Well, I don't
know cause I haven't, are you,
is this a specific example that you read
about or something or you just kind of
assuming that that's what the
mindset is? Yeah. Well, um,
I had read about like the slippery
slope situation, but it really,
it's like two perspectives.
One is like when you're in the mix and
the the next step or down the slippery
slope, the is always totally
understandable, right? No
one's going to run, know,
sound, the alarm. I bet if you looked at
the Bernie Madoff where he has had that,
I, I would, I would have to read about it,
but it would make sense to me
that your assumption is correct.
That in the beginning he wasn't like,
you know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to rip off a bunch of people.
I met at the beginning, you said,
you know what?
I got these good investments.
I'm going to get these people didn't
buy in. And then he goes, you know what?
I didn't quite make what
we were going to make,
but I'm just going to go ahead and take
some of these other people's money and
just distribute it to everyone
was kind of happy. And you know,
that's where it starts.
Yeah. And then you,
then you realize you can get away with
it and you go on down that road. Yeah.
And that,
and that's ego by the way,
because that's just ego
because you're like,
I don't want to admit to everybody that,
hey,
I didn't make the money I promised you
so you know what I'm going to do double
down, double down. But the tooth
perspectives is kind of the, the,
um,
the thing where when you're in the mix,
that one step is like, that's hard
to see in a matter of speaking.
It's hard to see, cause you're
like, Eh, why should I, you know,
this guy came in 30 seconds late,
so what?
I'm going to reprimand him in front of
everyone. Come on. You know, like really,
you know, so no one's, you know,
that's, that's easy to understand.
But every last employee never coming
in on time. You're like, no way.
Impossible. No Way. When I started this,
no way I would ever let that happen.
But here's the thing, it will happen
with that, you know, because of that,
because each little step is hard to see.
You can't see it.
That's why it's like this is the rule and
straight up. So you know sticklers of,
you know, people like when they're
sticklers on the rules. It's kind of like,
I guess made me, me like socially the
norm is like, hey, he's a stickler,
he's a Tightwad, whatever, you
know. But I will say this though,
you said that there is
also the way to lead,
like when you heard about Benton Benton
want to call the guy out like that,
but he would have just given
him a look. Right? Right.
Don't you think it's a good idea?
Don't you think it's really
important that we are on time? Yeah.
You don't want to call them out in
front of everybody or I permitted him,
but he still would have been a leader.
You still would've led and that's,
that's the, that's what
we want to do. Yeah. Yeah.
So I guess we'll uh,
yeah,
save the questions from the
interwebs for next time.
He native American names at the coolest
man. They do have the coolest names.
But if I, if, if I had another son, I
think I named him bloody knife. No. Right.
Or what was the other one in the
family. One stab. Yeah. Yeah. Dad.
Yeah. Native Americans definitely
knew how to put their names together.
And so what, like what's the,
what's the formula? It's like Oh,
some significant thing that this guy
did and we'll just call them. No,
you remember,
wouldn't like,
cause his name was each from the hand
and then they changed it from each,
I think it was each from his
hand or each from the hand.
Once he proved that he was actually
a, a, a Badass Warrior, his dad said,
cause he had,
he had requested the name from,
from his uncle because they could
both win. They could both walk,
they could both walk the
distance long and never give up.
And so he requested that name and
when a, once they fought it, the bid,
little big horn, he introduced
his son as, this is my son,
wouldn't like my,
uh,
Sarah before they were like,
Hey,
I wonder how the native Americans
get their name. I know how they just,
when they do something significant,
they just, they just give it to them.
They don't make up a name surrounding
it. That's their name, what they do.
So her friend Abby,
she smoked a lot at the time.
So her name was Abby smokes
a lot. The legitimately, no,
oh, that's her native
American name. But, but the,
in the warrior culture it's way
cooler. You know what I mean? Yeah.
I like dances with wolves.
I mean that's probably not where your
culture then you ever seen that movie
dancing? I have seen that movie, but it
was a long time ago. That was when I went,
still went to movies before.
I just found them all kind of lame
old school for sure.
Yeah. All right. Um, well
I guess with that,
how about you talk about
how we can get in the game,
getting the game, the game and
still a little support the podcast.
Maybe it would be nice to
learn how to enforcement.
If you want to support the podcast,
you can do it and this is how, yeah,
there's some cool ways. Um,
if you don't know already,
I would say with supporting this podcast,
support yourself. That's, I think that
because if you're incapable, how are,
you know,
if you're not capable of supporting
yourself humping to support podcast,
how can you support us with that?
By the way,
we got mixed reviews
from the last podcast.
I had said something along the lines
of, hey, does this take too long?
Actually I did. We didn't get mixed
reviews. I think the only roof,
the only reviews we got were positive.
Now there might be some people that just
didn't say anything because they were
trying to be kind and gentle. Yeah. So
that's fine. They press stop right now.
The rest of the people that are kind
of like the little deep in the game,
they're deepen the game. Yeah,
that's a good, well, in a way I,
and there were some good points that
they brought up because, um, oh,
I forget who said it, but they were like,
there's some nuggets in there. Yeah. No,
we don't stop trying to learn.
Yeah.
While we're talking about things
that help us. Right. Correct.
We were still trying to
figure some stuff out. Yeah.
There's some nuggets of information to
share that might be dropped at any time.
Yeah.
And even if not,
that's part of the reason why
I put the guide, you know,
on Youtube. Oh yeah. This is, you guys
are done talking about this stuff,
so just turn it off. Oh, the
whatever the, the Internet stuff.
I'll just skip that part.
Yeah.
You can skip it and it'll tell you where
to skip too. So both options are there.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because some people might just want to
take everything they can from the podcast.
That's why I put, um, you know, the
timestamp for all the subjects because,
you know,
look,
I like to assume that
every 100% of the people,
everybody 10 out of 10,
like every single word of that, and they
like every single subject and they like,
I would, I like, I like to think that, but
in the event of that not being the case,
I don't want them to be all this while
I got to sit through echo talking about,
you know, Amazon Click throughs and on
it, you know, so they have the option.
I think that's important. Yeah. We're
all here. We're working together.
I feel like we're all in this together.
You know, we don't need the one guy being,
hey, I have a different opinion
than you. I have that. Right.
And then now I've got to sit through
this stuff that you guys like what I'm
saying. Well, I think we're taking care
of both sides in sure. So, and to do that,
you know, of course, like I said,
you support yourself
supplementation if you're into it.
And here's the thing where I didn't
think that like Krill oil with
supplementation. Here's the thing. It is,
and it helps cause that's cause you're,
you're now on the chrome
on the Krill oil and it,
and I have reaped its benefits and um,
my,
my wife's dad was talking about Krill
oil from, oh, fish oil, no, not fish oil.
Fish oil is good. Don't get me wrong.
It's outstanding. It's just, you know,
what's better? Krill oil is what he would
say on a time. And I'm like, Eh, yeah,
yeah. He's kind of, you know,
one of these health like guys
and I'm the old message.
No marriage. Yeah. So, um,
yeah, Krill oil from, from on it. Of
course. That's it. That's the main one.
They have like the quality,
the quality stuff, cheap stuff.
No, don't. And He, one
might think, oh yeah,
of course I'm not going to go get the
cheap stuff, but here's the thing.
And slept with supplements.
Like there is cheap stuff.
There's like stuff that
straight up doesn't work.
Like you might as well be taking
chop condensed into pills. It's true.
Absolutely true. Chalk you said? Yeah.
Okay. Don't do that. Cause it's not like,
I don't know something about it
being a supplement. It's not rigged.
I Dunno something, but on it is all
legit, like it has the literature,
all that stuff like where they get it.
Even the Krill oil is like,
you're so excited about where the Krill
oil comes from. Always. That's a deal.
Like I said,
we're all that.
You're about to tell us
about the environmental
friendly ships. You love that.
That was kind of a cool video
too. You can see. No, I liked it.
That obviously left an impression
on you and for you to say something,
it's a cool video.
That's a pretty good compliment.
You kind of like cool
videos and make them,
at least we hope I tell
myself that. Yeah, sure.
Because a lot of times if we
don't make them, you don't make,
sometimes you make one every three
months and then how do we feel about that
there? We don't feel really good about
it yet. All right. There you go. I mean,
I'm okay. You know, I
take your point fully,
but back to the Krill oil.
It's good. Anyway. What else?
Nick Krill oil warrior bars.
The shroom tech for performance.
You know, if you, if you want the edge,
that sounds like kind of commercially,
but for real, if you want the edge, if
you want to get the edge, if you want,
you can alpha brain to elephant brain,
go and get them to work in mental edge.
Yeah. Anyway. And you can get 10%
off. You can support your wallet,
which is good to go to [inaudible]
dot com slash Jocko the home.
Also. Cool way, good way, legit
way. It doesn't cost you anything.
Way To support this podcast reinforces
vodcasts and be in the game.
Let's face it, it's much better to be
in the game, the game fully in here.
How's this, and this is on a side
note from this. Um, so you know,
like you know,
like people will go to like a
motivational seminar or something.
You don't like this or, or, or
listen to a motivational speech.
My motivational seminar
would be three minutes long.
So there's this like party brain where
you know it's seek something and then you
get the payoff and then it's,
it's basically a sense of satisfaction
so you can seek no more. So you're,
you're satisfied. So people
seeking inspiration and motivation,
they'll go in,
they'll go to a speech or a seminar or
something like this and they'll consume
the speech or the motivational video or
whatever. But they're spectating there.
Yeah, they're watching it. Inspecting,
yeah, the speech. Sure. Yeah.
So the whole lot different.
Really the big picture should be,
I'm going to get to see this
speech, motivation, video, whatever.
I'm going to be inspired, motivated.
Now I'm going to go take action, right.
But to take action, you still
have to have a need, you know,
that needs to be satisfied. But people,
they'll come, they'll view or, or, or,
you know, whatever, consume the speech
and they will be satisfied because they,
they see the speech and they don't
take action. And here's the thing,
the next speech that comes into town or
the next motivational video on youtube,
you know, how does the next one or
the next time, whoever the person is,
I don't know, Tony Robbins or whoever,
next time they're coming to town,
they're going to go for that good
stuff that they got last time.
They left a real satisfied
with, you know, getting to see,
hearing that and you know, viewing
that speech, they go, they do it again.
They get that sense. Satisfaction still
taking no action by the way. Not Good.
So it's like it's a weird,
it's a messed up cycle.
I think the big difference there is,
and that's is that those
literally you're watching. Yeah.
And you're spectating as opposed
to getting in the game. Yeah.
And see that's it. That's my really
my whole point where you know,
I'm going to listen to you.
You're not saying like,
I mean you're saying get after,
but you're not saying you can do it.
You're not saying that kind of stuff.
You know, like I know it goes by,
I'm actually, I'm actually not saying
you can do it. I'm actually saying do it.
Yeah, exactly right. But that's the
thing. So really the whole message,
whatever it may be, you know,
I don't know. Big, don't eat
donuts. All this stuff is,
the big message here is don't eat donuts.
I think it's a bunch of messages,
but the key there to them,
the whole message is you got to do it.
It's not like you can do it, you know,
and you're like, Hey, I can do it.
I feel good about that fact.
I'm good.
But this is like you gotta do you
gotta go out and do that? You know,
you can't just walk. You can just
watch. Okay. I think I'm convinced.
I'm saying that's the difference.
And so you're saying that Amazon,
the Amazon shopping, click
through the website, Jocko,
podcast.com little Amazon link.
It definitely helps.
And also we're all going to be
all up on Amazon for Christmas,
for the holiday season,
for whatever it is you're
going to celebrate when
school's off for two weeks and
you got to buy a bunch of people
presence yet during that time period.
That's a good time to support the podcast.
It doesn't cost you anything.
You Click through Amazon and you make
your purchases. The key there is to,
to remember it like you need some
kind of queue put in your bookmarks or
something. Done some kind of cute.
That's good. That's the key right there.
I think the rest is just,
it just kind of, you know,
it takes care of itself anyway.
And then you can subscribe of course,
on iTunes and Youtube and stitcher.
Google play. Yep. Yeah. Wherever you
might get your podcast from. Subscribe.
Yeah. Just subscribe. Write a
review. Right. A review. Yeah. Yeah.
Those are good men. Their reviews.
Yeah. Those are just, those are solid.
I like when people get creative.
I encourage that for sure.
Um, and then of course, of
course. Look, if you wear tee
shirts, if you wear hoodies,
drink coffee or tea of any kind
or white teeth anyway, Jocko, store.com
you can buy some cool shirts. Uh,
if you think they're cool,
you look at them,
there's going to be more to them
than meets the eye looking at a,
but if you like how they look,
maybe look into down, but here,
here's the thing though. I, you know, I'm
making like a so mysterious like, Ooh,
there's all these layers. How I
always say, yeah. Then the Hoodie,
one side says discipline other
sites. This freedom, if you look,
if you pay attention, there's a little
equal sign and it's a barcode. Yup.
That's made into equals sign. Someone
hit me on Twitter and said, hey,
you're talking about the layers. Is
this equal sign a layer, you know? Yeah.
Like is this a little hidden thing?
Yeah.
Hey, you're going to leave us here in
suspense. Yeah. It is a hidden thing.
It's not that big of a deal, but it's
a small deal. It's like a double,
like the, okay, here.
Here it is. So the font,
right? Yes. Jocko chose the font.
Yes. It would be for any of this.
Things started talking with chose the fun.
Yeah,
because I made the Jocko podcast.
You,
despite you being a massive,
you know,
skills with all those programs that
do all the design and you have a great
graphics mind and all that stuff. Despite
all that, I just made this little thing,
a little Jocko podcast symbol and I made
it on PowerPoint and when it came time
to pick the font,
I chose this font called OCR,
optical,
something recognition.
Because in my mind I'm always like,
okay, part machine, I'm part machine.
So this font can be read by machines.
Yup.
That is why that is why I
use this font. Yeah. So yeah,
you can look at that at the,
I don't know if you told me to look it up,
but you said it, you're like, oh
yeah, it's cool. It's like, Oh Dang.
So I looked it up and yeah,
sure enough,
it's the first point that they made
that computers can. Yes, that's right.
That is what it is. That's why I chose
it. I'm like, this guy's a deep cool. My,
all right,
so the Barcode,
okay.
Yes. Another thing that computer's going
to be reading your shirt kind of thing.
You're not machine. Yeah. Well, you're
wearing them. You're a machine readable.
You're a machine. Yes, yes,
you're wearing, that's what it is.
You can't get rid by computer.
So that's kind of the little late.
I mean that's just more of
like a fun thing for sure.
Small layer. Um, but anyway,
uh, again Jocko store, that's
where all the stuff is. Cool.
Rash guards that, hey man, we
made the claim 19% improvement.
That is yet to be refuted so far.
You know,
as far as feedback that
I've been getting anyway,
if you want your improvement because
you know what, you know what though?
I think that there is
legitimacy like actually full,
somebody put an article on today about
how it compresses the muscle increases
circulation so you actually
get the legit improvement.
I don't know all the science behind
it, you know, but bro Science, no,
but you know what is, you know how you
were saying, you know when you put on like
a uniform oh yeah.
You or you get a little yes as a ritual.
Back to the ritual conversation
kind of. And it's like, almost like,
it's weird,
like when I was young,
when I played football at 11
years old and we've got new shoes,
football season's here, new shoes.
Oh, I couldn't wait to go to practice.
I'm going to be faster few months, man.
My shoes are dirty. I hate practice.
But you get new shoes, you want to go
practice, you get new workout gear.
You're like, Dang, I'm going go. You get
a new rash guard, you want to go train.
And you knew, right? You get a new Geek,
you want to try it. Yeah. So that's
kind of, that's maybe a factor as well.
There's a little plastic. Oh yeah. Plus
Placebo. Sorry. Yeah, placebo factor.
Yeah. And that's, I call
it getting after it.
So chocolate [inaudible] dot com uh,
w some women's stuff,
some women's tee shirts
coming out soon. Oh, we now,
now that you say that, they
better be actually coming
out. So, you know, I think my,
my clock is counting down my Debbie clock.
Debbie gave me like a countdown mine
straight up dead. Right. You know,
she gave me one month,
she's leading up the chain of command.
Respect you respect on though.
But you can also get some Jocko white
tea if you want to drink some tea.
That tastes really good.
If you haven't tried it yet,
it doesn't taste like tea and it
doesn't taste like anything else.
It tastes like something really good.
So give it a shot.
And a lot of people have replaced every
other beverage in their diet with Jocko
white tea.
And on top of that we've got a little
something new coming out that can be used
for tea or for coffee or
for milk or for cream.
And it's a big old mug. So those
would be on Amazon. And the Mug,
it's just a big black mug.
And then written on the Mug
is just says get after it.
So Yep, you can, you can get one
of those. It also says approved.
It was approved in fact by me.
So you get those mugs
and they're pretty cool.
And then also you get the
book extreme ownership,
which I wrote with my brother
late Babin and um, pick it up.
You know what a lot of like what I did
is when people buy it for themselves and
then three days later after
they get done reading it,
they buy four more for the people that
are on their team and then they buy one
for their boss and then they buy one for
the five people that are in their peers
team and they just spread the word because
they want to make their life easier
by having people getting after it all
around them and take an extreme ownership.
And um, if you do want to kind
of keep, keep cruising with,
you know,
with Echo Charles and myself,
you can find this actually on
the interwebs, on the interwebs,
on Twitter,
on also on Instagram.
And also we're are kind
of all up on the Facebook,
Facebook if you want to get that echo
is at Charles and I am at jockowillink
and
okay,
I guess finally,
thanks for listening tonight everybody.
It's out there in uniform serving.
Yeah,
work with some police this,
this week I worked for some fire
departments this week. Awesome.
Thanks for what you do.
Thanks for your service.
Thanks for protecting the homeland,
folks that are overseas.
Thank you for what you're doing.
Stay aggressive.
Stay ahead of the enemy.
Keep getting after it.
And then to all the troopers that I'm
meeting all the time in every industry,
every industry you could imagine that
are out there making things happen,
turning and burning day
to day crushing things,
whether it's so massive project that
you are completely devoted to doing and
doing it perfectly.
Or you know what?
There's plenty of people that hit me
up and they say, Hey, you know what?
I gotta do a bunch of stupid
administrative tasks today and guess what?
I'm going to line them up
and I'm going to crush them.
So wherever you are on today,
on that Spec,
drum line, 'em up. Okay?
And crush them.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.